this is Diablo Canyon the last
functioning nuclear power plant in
California though scheduled to shut down
in 2025 the state recently extended its
operations by up to five more years
Global energy disruptions caused by
Russia's war in Ukraine and sky-high
fuel prices mean aging nuclear plants
are getting a new lease on life I I
think it's you know one of these
elements that just add up to the the the
the the pressure to see if if we can
continue uh operating these countries
including Germany Japan and the UK plan
to keep on running plants that had been
scheduled to close
even as traditional plants like this one
are having their life spans extended all
around the world a new type of nuclear
power plant is on the horizon one that
may change the industry forever they are
called small modular reactors or smrs
for short I think small modular reactor
technology is really going to be a game
changer for nuclear going forward smrs
are smaller and cheaper they can be
built in factories and delivered to
where they're needed so you can have
some really remote locations that just
need a little bit of power that can be a
boon for countries struggling to cut
fossil fuel emissions everybody's really
having a look at these small modular
reactors as part of their energy
equation some scientists say smrs are
safer than traditional reactors because
they don't need externally powered pumps
to replenish the water supply used to
keep fuel rods from overheating the
reactors are are are actually immersed
in a big pool of water and that pool is
sufficient to cool off the reactors
there is no
power requirement to safely shut down
these reactors so no meltdown
no still other scientists say smr's lack
of a robust containment system like the
giant concrete domes on conventional
plants could present a danger but U.S
Regulators have already approved one
company's SMR design with more than 70
commercial SMR designs on the drawing
board worldwide experts say the first
smrs will be operational sometime in the
next decade Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera San
Luis Obispo California